good morning believe nation today's
message is you are unique over to you
pony trend Jen I wake up every mood in
espresso TV go there is nobody on planet
earth like you and you are unique you
have unique gifts that nobody else has
so as as quickly as you can accept that
the happier you will be why try and be
somebody else and why worry about others
accepting you i am who i am i'm proud of
the fact that i am this way and besides
i don't have a choice this is who I am
and so I am very accepting of the fact
that I come with and my wife is very
accepting of the fact that I come with a
certain package and it's taken me a
while to get comfortable with this is
who I am and these were the gifts that
were given to me by my parents and I'm
not trying to be somebody else I me and
I'm happy about that so I would say to
you your unique you have your own gifts
there's nobody else like you and just
get comfortable with that and that will
give you a sense of peace and frankly
tremendous confidence because you're not
trying to please somebody else you
trying to please yourself now it's
easier said than done because we're
trained from an early age to try and
please others I think that's a losing
battle because you ultimately end up
trying to be somebody else and I say
that about our firm as well I mean I say
in the u.s. that we aspire to lead the
profession we're not defined or
validated by comparing ourselves to
somebody else we don't care we don't
care what pwc does we don't care what
McKenzie does we don't care because
we're not going to be defined or
validated by comparing ourselves to them
where you need
we're special there is nobody else like
us so we are going to define the
profession in our image and I think that
applies to individuals as well we're all
unique and if you try and be somebody
else I think you will be quite unhappy
people like to put us in boxes as
entrepreneurs I know that we don't like
having other people put us in a box
that's far why we left that company and
started our own thing but as
entrepreneurs I find that we box
ourselves in as well and we define
ourselves based on what other people are
doing and you have to understand that as
long as you were comparing yourself to
somebody else you're never going to have
ultimate success because your goal is to
be the best version of yourself not to
try to copy and be somebody else and I
get this a lot of my top 10 rules these
a lot of misunderstanding around it I
made the top ten rules as people that
you want to model but not copy right I'm
not I don't want to be Steve Jobs or
Martha Stewart or Oprah Winfrey I want
to be the best version of myself and I
learned to do that by modeling the
success strategies wisdom ideas of
people who've done a lot more than me so
if you see a top pen video from somebody
who you don't have a lot of respect for
maybe you don't like Steve Jobs maybe we
thought it was a terrible leader in a
terrible manager maybe that's your
opinion great you can still learn
something from steve jobs to help you be
the best version of yourself and that's
the goal i get a lot of people who will
copy the stuff that I'm doing right
people have copied my believe slogan and
they've copied Milo going icon and you
know use their own name instead and
people write to me and say are you
worried about it you know I've had
people copy my top 10 videos and do the
exact same video but they put themselves
at the front and they do their own
version of the three points that I say
and people say Evan do you worry about
that what should you do about it like I
don't care because as long as you're
just trying to copy me you're never
going to achieve anything great
right you cannot out Evan Evan it's not
possible right you can't be a better
version of me than me the trick though
is to then model something that I might
be doing and put your own spin on it
that's where success will come not by
just trying to copy what I'm doing but
modeling my success to then put your own
spin and do something successful in your
own way and that's a challenge that I
have for you guys figure out what's
unique about you pole and learn from all
these people who've done a lot more to
make you the best version of yourself so
the question of the day today is I want
to know what is so unique about you
leave it in the comments below I'm
really curious to find out we're going a
little deeper today I'm excited to see
what you guys have to say thank you so
much for watching have an amazing day
you need to believe and i'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events press oh okay